le référendum sur la privatisation
d'aéroports de paris refait parler de
lui
trois mois après la clôture de la
pétition en faveur dans la ferme à domme
d'initiative partagée
le conseil constitutionnel a relevé des
défauts sur la plateforme en ligne
les sages blâme l'ergonomie du site
internet juge la procédure dissuasive
ils estiment le nombre de signatures
nécessaires très élevé chien un avis
partagé par le député communiste alain
bruneel il appelle le président à
respecter ses engagements
moi je connais beaucoup de gazole que
londres aurait un peu partout dans les
déplacements et à chaque fois que je
posais la question effectivement pour la
signature concernera restera donc à
chaque fois il me disait j'ai essayé sur
le site à chaque fois on me dit que mon
code par exemple comme de la vie ne
correspond pas il y avait toujours un
petit problème qui était compliqué donc
à la fin les gens les uns voisin mais 15
plus mignon cessera ordinaire je pense
qu'on aurait dû atteindre 14,7
pareil quand même que le président de la
république a dit à un moment donné dans
un de ses discours
si un million de signatures je suis prêt
à en discuter et au niveau de
l'assemblée nationale u au niveau du ch
est mal mais on signatures liées aussi
présents il faut candidat il faut qu'on
discute
il faut vous organiser leur a donc donné
aux mauvaises